Were we all starved for action after the pandemic?
Were the co-stars simply too good to miss? Or can
the box office bonanza of "John Wick: Chapter
4" be credited entirely to Keanu Reeves?
"... Yeah."
Keanu Reeves is no stranger to the action/thriller
genre. The actor broke with his early career
type-casting when he starred in 1999's "The
Matrix," which was written and directed by
the Wachowskis. "The Matrix" spawned its own
franchise, with two sequels in 2003 and a
fourth film in 2021, all featuring Reeves in his
now-iconic role as hacker turned cyber freedom
fighter Neo. However, in the years following "The
Matrix," Reeves' career hit something of a slump.
Things changed when the first "John Wick"
film arrived in 2014 and Reeves triumphantly
returned to being an action star. The film
stars Keanu as the titular ex-assassin who
comes out of retirement to get revenge on the
gangsters who killed his puppy and stole his
car. It proved to be the perfect vehicle to
re-launch Reeves' career as an action hero.
"People keep asking if I'm back.
And I haven't really had an answer.
But now, yeah, I'm thinking I'm back."
As opposed to the effects-heavy fight scenes of
"The Matrix," "John Wick" reshaped action films
by emphasizing the use of practical effects and
flowing choreography. This trend continued into
the film's production style, with directors
Chad Stahelski and David Leitch deploying
long takes that kept the action clear and
in focus with an emphasis on the stunt work.
This involved extensive rehearsals
and pre-production planning,
but it all culminated in an action film that
stood out and established a unique franchise.
The first "John Wick" film
did well at the box office,
accruing $86 million against a fairly small
budget of $20 million. Its surprise success
gave Keanu Reeves and director Chad Stahelski
the opportunity to reunite for the sequel,
"John Wick: Chapter 2," released in 2017.
This time, the film's budget increased but
produced even greater returns at the box office
while receiving even more favor from critics.
Even though many critics appreciated how
neatly tied-up the first "John Wick" film was,
the further expansion of the universe
proved fruitful. In 2019, "John Wick:
Chapter 3 — Parabellum" was released in
theaters, following Keanu's character on
the run after his excommunication from
the High Table put him in the sights of
seemingly every assassin in the world. Meanwhile,
spin-offs were put into motion as early as 2017,
including an upcoming Peacock miniseries
titled "The Continental" centered on the
backstory of the eponymous underworld
hotel with Mel Gibson set to star.
These days, it can be quite challenging for an
original IP to find a place for itself among
franchises, but Keanu Reeves' feels that audiences
are picking up on the film's authenticity. In
2019, Reeves spoke with "Collider" talking
about how the films are very easy to watch,
highlighting the thrill of moviegoing
that the "John Wick" franchise exploits.
The 2010s were an era of reinvention for many
film genres that had become stale. Jordan
Peele's "Get Out" revolutionized the horror
genre while directors like Greta Gerwig and
Olivia Wilde created a new generation of iconic
coming-of-age movies for teens to fall in love
with. In a similar vein, the first "John Wick''
felt like a return to form for a once-great genre.
In anticipation of "John Wick:
Chapter 3 – Parabellum," "Rolling Stone"
recalled the first film's success as:
"the beginning of what would become the
seriously bats--t-crazy, go-for-broke,
open-world action-flick
franchise of the 21st century."
They emphasized how dearly missed action
films like "John Wick" were. In certain ways,
"John Wick" calls back to the days
of Sylvester Stallone as John Rambo
tearing through the jungle, or even Bruce
Willis as John McClane heroically saving
his marriage and Nakatomi Plaza
from terrorists in "Die Hard."
"Come out to the coast, we'll
get together, have a few laughs."
Much of this nostalgia and love have
to do with "John Wick" as a franchise
remaining loyal to highly-choreographed
fight scenes, incredibly complex stunts,
gruesome yet entertaining violence, and a
smorgasbord of great action movie influences.
In the 2020s, it's proven hard to have a
successful theater run if your movie isn't
part of a franchise. Even critically-acclaimed
directors like Damien Chazelle or Robert Eggers
have seen their theatrical epics falter at the
box office, as was the case with their films
"Babylon" and "The Northman." It's much easier
for success to land with sequels or spin-offs,
such as 2023's "Creed III," or fan service
favorites like Marvel's "Spider-Man: No Way Home."
It's a problem that poses a dilemma for movie
theater chains. The Hollywood Reporter reveals
that many theaters underperformed in 2022
despite big releases like "Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever" and "Avatar: The Way of
Water," the latter of which grossed over $2
billion. Although things have greatly improved
since the start of the COVID-19 pandemic, it's
hard to attract movie fans to the theater when
so many high-profile releases are simultaneously
released to streaming or available within
a few months of their theatrical release.
Still, not every movie studio can bank
on a word-by-mouth hit like the recent
best picture winner "Everything Everywhere
All At Once," but this is where "John Wick:
Chapter 4" likely benefits. With a studio like
Lionsgate backing it, it's hard for anybody to be
oblivious to the release of the latest "John Wick"
adventure, thanks to marketing, the attachment
of a likable star, and the overall popularity
of the previous three films in the franchise.
While one can credit a lot of the box office
success of "John Wick" to its originality
as a franchise and the sheer thrill of
watching films like it on a big screen,
no one can deny that at the center of it
all lies one secret weapon: Keanu Reeves.
"That's cool! That's kind!"
Reeves is even more talked-about than
his ex-hitman character on the internet,
with many sharing stories about their encounters
with the actor in public. Whether it's donating
his salary to crew members on his films or
going out of his way to give autographs to
fans who are too nervous to ask him, it's
hard not to fall in love with Reeves.
As if there wasn't enough proof of
Reeves' awesomeness and humility,
the actor seems modest about the love
his fans have for him, recently telling
People that he "really appreciate[s]
the goodwill" sent his way online.
The "John Wick" franchise went on something
of a hiatus due to forced production delays
resulting from the COVID-19 pandemic. "John
Wick: Chapter 4" didn't even enter principal
photography until the summer of 2021,
with a release intended for May 2022.
That release window for "Chapter 4" was
complicated by the impending release of
"Top Gun: Maverick" on the same day in
2022, which resulted in it being pushed
back to early 2023. By the time "Chapter
4" finally premiered in late March 2023,
fans had been waiting more than
four years for the next installment.
The release of "Chapter 4" in 2023 is also
coinciding with an easier return to the theater
for many. During the COVID-19 pandemic, lots of
people felt hesitant to return to the movies,
especially when many studios released films on
streaming services shortly after their theatrical
release, if not entirely in place of it. However,
an action movie with a big star seems to be just
the project to woo even the most pandemic-cautious
moviegoers back into those seats.
It's no secret that Keanu Reeves and
Laurence Fishburne make a dynamite duo on
the big screen. The two actors first appeared
together in 1999's "The Matrix," with Keanu
playing the lead role of Neo and Fishburne
giving an iconic performance as Morpheus,
the human rebel who introduces Neo to the truth
behind the dystopian future he lives in. The
two reprised their roles in "The Matrix
Reloaded" and "The Matrix Revolutions,"
though they spent many years apart following
the temporary end to "The Matrix" trilogy.
While Keanu returned as Neo in "The Matrix
Resurrections," Fishburne notably did not
re-appear as Morpheus, who was instead
replaced with "Watchmen" actor Yahya
Abdul-Mateen II as an artificial intelligence
designed after Fishburne's deceased character.
The two have starred together in the "John
Wick" franchise ever since "John Wick:
Chapter 2," where Fishburne debuted as the
Bowery King, the leader of an underground
spy organization allied with Reeves' titular
character. Fishburne returned in "John Wick:
Chapter 3 — Parabellum," as well as "John
Wick: Chapter 4," which should satisfy
"The Matrix" fans who missed the actor's
appearance in "The Matrix Resurrections."
"Afterall, a man has to look his
best when he gets married…or buried."
A new face appearing in "John Wick: Chapter 4" may
also represent a big draw for audiences to see it
on the big screen. It was reported in 2021 that
Japanese-British pop artist Rina Sawayama would be
making her feature film debut in the latest "John
Wick" film. Sawayama's music career particularly
took off in 2020 with the release of her album
"Sawayama," which was lauded by critics for its
nostalgic factors and ambition in the pop sphere.
Sawayama has continued to collaborate with notable
artists like Charli XCX and Elton John leading
up to her 2022 sophomore album "Hold the Girl."
Given the aesthetic of her music and her
performance in music videos for her songs,
she was an easy choice to play the role of
Akira in "John Wick: Chapter 4." According
to director Chad Stahelski, Sawayama "seemed
right out of an anime," in an interview with
"NME." The role of Akira takes advantage
of this, even with very little screen time.
In the film, Akira is the daughter
of the Osaka Continental's manager,
Koji Shimazu. Koji protects John
Wick from the High Table's enforcers
and ultimately dies in the ensuing conflict.
Fans of Sawayama's music will be thrilled to
see her in the action film, and her audience
will definitely buy movie tickets to see it.
Unfortunately, the latest installment in the
"John Wick" franchise is not without tragedy.
In March 2023, only days after its premiere
in London, actor Lance Reddick sadly passed
away. The actor, known for his performances
in "The Wire" and "Lost" was a staple of
the "John Wick" franchise since the very
first film, where he debuted as Charon,
the concierge of the Continental and a
close confidante of its manager, Winston.
While all of his "John Wick" co-stars have been
vocal in their grief, Keanu Reeves paid special
tribute to Reddick, calling him "a beautiful,
special person" in an interview with CNN and
donning a blue ribbon in remembrance of the actor.
Other eulogies poured in from franchise director
Chad Stahelski, as well as Reddick's former
collaborators David Simon and James Gunn.
"John Wick: Chapter 4" won't be the last
time audiences will have the opportunity
to watch Lance Reddick perform posthumously.
The actor has many future projects lined up,
including the "John Wick" spin-off
"Ballerina," the "Percy Jackson and
the Olympians" TV adaptation on Disney+, and the
2023 remake of "White Men Can't Jump." However,
"John Wick: Chapter 4" has nonetheless been
a great opportunity for fans to head to the
movie theater and see one of Reddick's final
performances as the iconic Continental concierge.
Many moviegoers are flocking to see "John Wick:
Chapter 4" purely because of its stellar
reviews. The previous three entries in the
franchise were all well-received by critics,
but "Chapter 4" clearly raised the bar.
Wendy Ide of The Guardian showered the
fourth installment with praise, writing:
"You expect that the stunts and fight
choreography of a John Wick film will be
top tier [...] But even by the standards of
the past Wick outings, this is remarkable."
Richard Brody of The New Yorker labeled it "by far
the best of the four films," and Manohla
Dargis of the New York Times called it,
"Pure, eye-popping, body-shaking,
transporting entertainment."
The film is not without its detractors,
such as a reviewer for Consequence who
criticized the film's thematic
low points and lack of coherence,
but still found lots to praise about
its spectacle. But by and large,
the critics love it – it earned a 94% on Rotten
Tomatoes, based on more than 280 reviews.
The "John Wick" franchise has slowly
become one of the biggest original IPs
of the 2010s. Nevertheless, "John Wick:
Chapter 4" seems to be the end for now,
with director Chad Stahelski telling The
Hollywood Reporter that he and Keanu Reeves
plan to "give John Wick a rest." Though he
admits it would always be possible for him
and Keanu to have discussions that lead to
another film. For now, seeing "John Wick:
Chapter 4" is an opportunity that fans
of the franchise shouldn't miss out on.
However, the franchise isn't going anywhere.
Ana de Armas is set to star as Rooney,
a ballerina assassin played by Unity Phelan in
"John Wick: Chapter 3," in a spin-off film titled
"Ballerina" currently set to be released in 2024.
Keanu Reeves, Lance Reddick, and Ian McShane are
all confirmed to be reprising their roles from
the primary "John Wick" films in "Ballerina,"
which itself may branch out into its own film
franchise if it goes over well with audiences.
Right now, chances seem slim for a fifth "John
Wick." Reeves and Stahelski seem to be content
with leaving the franchise behind. While
the box office success of the latest film
has the studio thinking otherwise, it all comes
down to Keanu's interest in reprising the role.
"You uh… working again? No,
just sorting some stuff out."